I'm McKenna Pope. I'm 14 years old,
and when I was 13, I convinced
one of the largest toy companies,
toymakers, in the world, Hasbro,
to change the way that they marketed
one of their most best-selling products.
So allow me to tell you about it.
So I have a brother, Gavin.
When this whole shebang happened, he was four.
He loved to cook.
He was always getting ingredients out of the fridge
and mixing them into these, needless to say,
uneatable concoctions,
or making invisible macaroni and cheese.
He wanted to be a chef really badly.
And so what better gift for a kid
who wanted to be a chef
than an Easy-Bake Oven. Right?
I mean, we all had those when we were little.
And he wanted one so badly.
But then he started to realize something.
In the commercials, and on the
boxes for the Easy-Bake Ovens,
Hasbro marketed them specifically to girls.
And the way that they did this
was they would only feature girls
on the boxes or in the commercials,
and there would be flowery prints all over the ovens
and it would be in bright pink and purple,
very gender-specific colors to females, right?
So it kind of was sending a message
that only girls are supposed to cook; boys aren't.
And this discouraged my brother a lot.
He thought that he wasn't
supposed to want to be a chef,
because that was something that girls did.
Girls cooked; boys didn't,
or so was the message that Hasbro was sending.
And this got me thinking,
God, I wish there was a way that I could change this,
that could I have my voice heard by Hasbro
so I could ask them and tell them
what they were doing wrong
and ask them to change it.
And that got me thinking about a website
that I had learned about a few months prior
called Change.org.
Change.org is an online petition-sharing platform
where you can create a petition and share it
across all of these social media networks,
through Facebook, through Twitter,
through YouTube, through Reddit, through Tumblr,
through whatever you can think of.
And so I created a petition
along with the YouTube video
that I added to the petition
basically asking Hasbro
to change the way that they marketed it,
in featuring boys in the commercials, on the boxes,
and most of all creating them
in less gender-specific colors.
So this petition started to take off --
humongously fast, you have no idea.
I was getting interviewed by
all these national news outlets
and press outlets, and it was amazing.
In three weeks, maybe three and a half,
I had 46,000 signatures on this petition.
(Applause)
Thank you.
So, needless to say, it was crazy.
Eventually, Hasbro themselves
invited me to their headquarters
so they could go and unveil
their new Easy-Bake Oven product to me
in black, silver and blue.
It was literally one of the best moments of my life.
It was like &quot;Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.&quot;
That thing was amazing.
What I didn't realize at the time, however,
was that I had become an activist,
I could change something,
that even as a kid, or maybe
even especially as a kid,
my voice mattered, and your voice matters too.
I want to let you know it's not going to be easy,
and it wasn't easy for me,
because I faced a lot of obstacles.
People online, and sometimes even in real life,
were disrespectful to me and my family,
and talked about how the whole
thing was a waste of time,
and it really discouraged me.
And actually, I have some examples,
because what's better revenge
than displaying their idiocy?
So, let's see.
From user name Liquidsore29 --
interesting user names we have here—
&quot;Disgusting liberal moms making their sons gay.&quot;
Liquidsore29, really? Really? Okay.
How about from Whiteboy77AGS:
"People always need something
to (female dog) about."
From Jeffrey Gutierrez:
&quot;OMG, shut up. You just want money and attention.&quot;
So it was comments like these
that really discouraged me from
wanting to make change in the future
because I thought, people don't care,
people think it's a waste of time,
and people are going to be disrespectful
to me and my family.
It hurt me, and it made me think,
what's the point of making change in the future?
But then I started to realize something.
Haters gonna hate.
Come on, say it with me. One, two, three:
So let your haters hate,
you know what, and make your change,
because I know you can.
I look out into this crowd,
and I see 400 people
who came out because they wanted to know
how they could make a change,
and I know that you can, and all
of you watching at home can too
because you have so much that you
can do and that you believe in,
and you can trade it across all these social media,
through Facebook, through Twitter, through
YouTube, through Reddit, through Tumblr,
through whatever else you can think of.
And you can make that change.
You can take what you believe in
and turn it into a cause and change it.
And that spark that you've been
hearing about all day today,
you can use that spark that you have within you
and turn it into a fire.
Thank you.
(Applause)